the opportunities are there but you
gotta reach out and pick them up
i feel lucky uh that i fell into doing
something
um that i feel really matters you know
getting people
information uh around the world about
anything we're spending all our time
trying to blame people and figure out
why we got to where we are now
rather than focusing on how you get out
of where we are now and make it better
want to be happy build a life not just a
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know you've got
something more inside you
you've got michael jordan level of
genius at something so today let's live
your best believe life and get inside
the incredible mindset of billionaires
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one learn from every mistake with oprah
winfrey
it doesn't matter how far you might rise
at some point
you are bound to stumble because if
you're constantly doing
what we do raising the bar
if you're constantly pushing yourself
higher higher
the law of averages not to mention the
myth the vigorous
uh predicts that you will at some point
fall and when you do i want you to know
this remember this
there is no such thing as failure
failure is just life
trying to move us in another direction
now when you're down there in a hole it
looks like
failure so this past year i had to spoon
feed those words to myself
and when you're down in the hole when
that moment comes it's really okay to
feel
bad for a little while give yourself
time to mourn what you think you may
have lost
but then here's the key learn
from every mistake because every
experience encounter and particularly
your mistakes
are there to cheat you and force you
into being
more of who you are rule number two
seize the day
with steve bomber there's a latin
expression
which i think is great i love it it was
in a
now very old movie called the dead poet
society but the line of the movie was
carpe diem
seize the day the opportunities are
there
but you got to reach out and pick them
up you've got to grab at them
some of you may have already done that
at the u in your classes
in other students that you met in your
extracurricular activities but grab them
don't be afraid to make a mistake
because you know what you can do if you
grab the wrong one
drop it and pick up another one it's
okay
seize the day i think back of all of the
the the luck but also the times that
were in front of me
to seize the day i don't know what got
me to drop out of business school
and come to microsoft my parents thought
i was a whack job
neither one of them graduated college
and they thought this was really a wild
idea
i was lucky i seized the day
microsoft one day some guys fly in
from from ibm and all of a sudden we
figure out we could actually
provide all the software they need for
this thing that became
the personal computer people
bill paul they had the wisdom to seize
the day when that opportunity presented
itself
and yet when you think of all the
opportunities when i think back of all
the opportunities i've had
the one that was most important was an
opportunity i got
1969 sitting in my
junior high school class i was in a
public junior high
not very stimulated at the time and over
the loudspeaker
they said that private high school in
our area that i'd never heard of
was giving scholarship tests that
weekend
i told my mother i wanted to take him
she said that's fine as long as you get
a scholarship because we can't afford to
send you there
but that's really where i got switched
on switched on in math switched on
personally
energized in a way that never never
could be turned back and i'm very
thankful
for that opportunity yes there's a lot
of luck
in opportunity but there's a lot of
seizing the day
and i encourage you all to reach out and
carpe diem really sees the opportunities
that are in front of you
rule number three give the best
experiences with mark zuckerberg
there's this inherent conflict in the
system though which is you know are we
trying to optimize news feed to give
each person all of you guys the best
experience when you're reading
or are we trying to help businesses just
reach as many people as possible
and in every decision that we make we
optimize for the first
for making it so that when for the
people um who we serve who use facebook
and who are reading news feed
um get the very best experience that
they can and that means that
if a business is sharing content that's
going to be useful for them
then we'll show that but that means that
if the business is sharing content that
isn't going to be useful for them
um we may not show that because it's
probably more important that they learn
about their friend who had a baby and
their baby is healthy
so that's an important guiding principle
for how we think about this stuff
and as the um and as the products
continue to develop there's just going
to be
more people sharing more things and
we're going to continue to try to do our
best at
showing the best things that we can
understanding that there's no way that
we can
that a person will ever take the time to
go through every one of the 1500 things
that are shared with them every single
day um so that's
but that's kind of how i think about
organic reach and um
you know there are a lot of pages that
are going that are doing quite
successfully and their organic reach is
is growing quite a bit because
they're delivering content to people
that they really want so if you're a
business owner and you're thinking about
how to use
your free page on facebook i would just
focus on trying to
publish really good content that's going
to be compelling to your customers and
the people who are following you
rule number four learn the money game
with grant cardone
i worked at mcdonald's i got fired i
worked at a furniture store i got fired
i worked in a car dealership i was fired
six times from the same guy
i just quit leaving and i've been fired
so many times i finally figured out how
to get fired and keep my job i mean
really
so talent uh i'm i'm a sales guy
because not because i wanted to that was
not something i wanted to do
uh my dad my dad was a sales guy my dad
told my mom before he died
tell those boys to learn how to sell he
knew he was going to die and he's like
tell those boys to learn how to sell and
they can go anywhere
uh i i didn't know that my mom didn't
tell me that until i was like
uh 25 26 years old and i had to take a
sales job
she she wanted me to be a more a
professional
uh so i went and got an accounting
degree got out of college there was 25
unemployment i didn't know it i i you
know i didn't i didn't know anything
about
sales i didn't i didn't go to college to
become a salesman
but it was the only job i could get when
i was 25 years old it was be unemployed
or take this job selling toyotas i
didn't even know what a toyota was
to th this is this is years ago toyota
wasn't even
uh a thing yet and um
so i took this job that i didn't i
thought it was just going to be a
temporary job i said okay i'm going to
do this for
until i can get a real job and
that ended up becoming my career i
actually hated sales
because all the jobs i had outside of
mcdonald's were
part-time sales jobs i sold clothes you
know i remember selling clothes i'd sell
i'd sell an outfit i'd make six bucks on
it
so kind of hard to get excited about six
dollars but it was six dollars more than
i had and i was trying to put myself
through college and
and pay for all kind of ridiculous
things i was doing at the time
and um i
i leaned into the sales thing and
started learning it i was just shooting
some material today for cardone
university we
we have probably without me over um
over promoting my own product we we
probably have
the most viewed sales training system in
the world today
and i'm saying that not to brag but to
tell the viewer
this came out of a job i didn't want and
didn't like
but when i leaned into it and said hey i
need to commit to this thing because i'm
just gonna
i have to learn how to do this i have to
learn how to bring revenue in
and whether i liked it or not i needed
to learn i needed to learn the money
game the money game starts with
in accounting and it might have been the
thing i learned in accounting as i sit
here and tell you the story because
in accounting the top
i remember studying financial statements
in accounting classes uh
it was uh counting um the principles of
accounting i thought i was gonna learn
how to make money
that's not what they're teaching there
but i remember there was on a page
in the accounting book the blue
accounting book that i tested and hated
there was a page about an income
statement and then they would compare
income statements of these companies
well the top thing of
every page was income revenue
or gross sales and
later looking back didn't know it then
but looking back later i'm like oh
that's the most important part of a
company
if it wasn't the most important part of
a company they wouldn't put it at the
top
of the income statement yeah that's when
every income statement everywhere in the
world it doesn't matter whether you're
in china or chicago
the top three lines they might be
different words there it is all
describing
gross sales revenue revenue by
department
uh gross demand domestic product how
much
revenue is coming through a country that
is what determines whether or not a
household
a department or a company is viable
and i have been fighting the top three
lines of my personal
financial statement which everybody has
one
and it's called sales so once i leaned
into it boom i started making money man
it was
it was literally that simple i'm going
to learn how to bring revenue into my
household
i was 25 years old had no money lived in
a
lived in an apartment and my rent was
275 a month
i was late on it four times a year every
three months i was late because i'd go
up and down
and when i leaned into it i was saying
hey i made an extra thousand
dollars uh when i was 25 years old i'm
like wow that was the most important
money i've ever made in my whole life
because it gave me an idea that i could
control my income
hey man how you doing buddy good how are
you you got a book coming out don't you
uh you just came out where can people
get it
get it on amazon easiest spot built to
serve
right there let's go man if you guys
don't know evan follow evan carmichael
he's got a new book out build a serve go
grab it today at amazon
there's a good dude right here rule
number five think independently with ray
dalio
you do our calculations and
we have a view that's very different
than the rest of the world's view at
that time
so the independent thinking we had among
ourselves different people who had
different views and the ability to work
ourselves through those and
was essential for us to being able to
stand upside from the crowd so i needed
to have the independent thinking and we
needed to work
it through and then even at that time we
had to have
the fear of being wrong because you can
never be confident that you're wrong
right in the markets and so to place the
bet but to place the bet
in a defensive way and to work out
together
um the engineering what what i believe
is
that everything happens over and over
again
through history world operates like a
machine it happens over and over again
and that if you can sort of go above
yourself and your circumstances
and look down at yourself within your
circumstances within a historical
perspective
and then have agreed upon principles
you know principles are how to handle
things that happen over and over again
by having that it's helpful and ours are
just oriented around this idea of
meritocracy so
it allowed us to have an independent
point of view while being
not a hundred percent certain and you
know to be defensive and
it allowed us to play that well rule
number six make a difference with sergey
brin
the challenge of a problem or the
importance uh isn't that
related how likely you are to achieve it
and
in fact even when you go after a more
ambitious goal even if you fail to
achieve that one
all the side effects that come along the
way can be that much more
uh rewarding and significant in their
own right
and so you know i feel lucky that i fell
into
doing something um that i feel really
matters you know getting people
information uh around the world about
anything
uh i i wish there was a way to convey
that too
uh you know to the world at large
obviously all of you
already have this religion but it's
uh very rewarding when you work on
something you think is going to make a
big difference
and uh yeah it's a little bit harder
but i think i think the passion that one
might bring with it
uh brings so much more energy to that
that you're more likely to succeed
and rule number seven the last one
before a very special bonus clip
is never look back with michael
bloomberg it's never
been a day that i haven't looked forward
to going into work even the days i knew
i was going to get beaten up
even the day i knew i was going to get
fired i'd never been fired before i
wonder what it's like
okay let's go find out yeah and i've
never
looked back i i find it fascinating
people spend and we're doing this in
this country
we're spending all our time trying to
blame people and figure out why we got
to where we are now
rather than focusing on how you get out
of where we are now and make it better
and successful people look to the future
and unsuccessful people look to the back
look behind them
now i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're going to enjoy but before
that
it's time for the question of the day i
want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video
and what is your plan of action for the
next week the sign says that when you
just watch a video you get motivated you
get inspired
you have a 35 chance of actually doing
something following through
that believe nation is not enough 35
is not enough we got to do something but
when you get inspired by watching a
video like this
and then you create a plan of action
your chances of following will jump
to 91 and when you commit publicly
like putting your comment down below
with your plan it jumps to 95
that's what i want for you i want you to
take action your dreams are too
important
your life matters your mission has to
happen
so question of the day your biggest
takeaway from this video and your plan
of action for the next week
put it down in the comments below and
i'm going to celebrate alongside with
you
you haven't said that this is the thing
this is what i have to accomplish today
this is the mission that i am on and
nothing is going
to stop me if you don't learn to focus
on what's important to you
you'll never do important things and
live your life
reacting to what's important to other
people instead
so i recently started a new business
with one of my thought leadership
academy students jeremy he came to my
event last year
i was thinking about him on my tour this
year and said i want to start a business
with jeremy around youtube consulting
i get asked a lot hey evan can you check
out my channel hey evan can i work with
you haven't can i hire you
for xyz looking at my channel giving me
ideas
mentoring guiding me and it's just not
the business that i want to be in but it
is a business
and so i thought jeremy jeremy's going
to come on board he's going to do it
now when i recruited him and called him
he was not a youtube expert
and i gave him the homework and said
listen if you want to do this business
together
it's got to be important to you i'm
halfway through my trip
on my tour i'm coming back in a month
and a half here's what i need you to
know by the end of the month and a half
and i gave him resources i gave him
videos i gave him insights and analytics
and said you need to know all of this
know all of this and then when i come
back if you're ready we'll start the
business
and he did he focused he made it his
priority he knew nothing about this
and all of a sudden he became an expert
by every day
all day long grinding to learn
by researching everybody who was an
expert at this understanding their
methodologies their best practices
looking through all my videos my
thumbnails my strategies all the things
that i've talked about in the past
digesting it kind of like the matrix
when neo's in the matrix and and he
now we can learn kung fu and now he
learns how to fly a helicopter
all of that stuff that's basically what
he did and when it came back in a month
and a half
i put him to the test and said hey let's
do two free calls we'll take two people
from my community and say hey
free free call let's go and he blew me
away with how much he knew
because he focused on it he was a guy
who went from knowing almost zero
to now being an expert to be able to
really help
give value to people and now when we're
looking at new people coming in
i barely have to do anything because he
already knows what i'm gonna say
he already knows he's already done the
work he's done the research because he
spent that time
on focused effort and this is where i
think a lot of people feel like they're
never gonna win because you may not have
had the expertise you don't have the
education
it doesn't take long to become an expert
it's just
focused work that you're passionate
about focused work you could quickly
become in a matter of months and expert
at something
if you just focus in on it and dedicate
your life to that thing
that you love you can easily pass people
who are experts at something who don't
love their thing
but because you're willing to take it on
you're willing to absorb think about
when you went to school
how much of the information you had in
your head but
you had to read over the page four times
so if you're at the same page four or
five six times because you got lost you
got distracted
that's not focused work because you
don't love that thing
i was wondering if you have any stock
tips for any of the students you know
who are all trying to uh make make a
little living
i didn't think they taught that in
georgetown
now the the best the best investment i
ever met well i bought a book in 1949
by a fellow named ben graham called the
intelligent investor i don't remember
what i paid
but aside from what i paid for my two
marriage licenses that was the best
investment i ever made
and uh uh it's very important
to have the right framework you need you
need
you need to have an approach to
investing that's sound and
graham's approach is simple uh
but some people uh
adopt to it and and which i did
immediately and and
most people don't um but if you have the
right philosophy
you will find opportunities uh
as you go through the next 20 30 40 50
years and
and frankly you're most likely to find
them uh
when in periods like five years ago when
we were having
the panic i mean uh
stocks sell at silly prices from time to
time
most stocks at one time or another sell
at very silly prices
and it doesn't take a high iq
to figure out that they're cheap but it
does take a temperament
that's willing to step up and actually
act
i tell people if they're going in the
investment business if you've got 160 iq
sell 30 points to somebody else because
you won't need it i mean that
that it yeah i mean i figured out very
early you don't have to be that smart of
this business which is fortunate
but you do have to have the right
temperament and you have to be able to
ignore
what other people are saying and and
simply look at the facts
and decide is this stock which is
selling it
x worth 2x and occasionally you'll find
things like that
and if when you don't find it you don't
do anything so
that's my generalized stock tip no names
you actually start a law firm and then
practice law for some period of time
i had no alternative
and then you actually had an army of
children almost immediately
i painted myself in quite a corner yeah
so zero choice is pretty powerful yeah
for sure yes of course
so so you practice law and then you
leave law
in the firm that you helped found and
move over to
investments well but
help us understand that that sounds
miraculous
in fact it was rather interesting i
probably got
paid about 350 000 in my first 13 years
of law practice
total and i had an army of children
and no capital to start with and
when i
[Music]
chose this alternative career i had over
three hundred thousand dollars in liquid
instruments so i had and that was 10
years of living expenses
so i was not a courageous venture some
admirable man i was a cautious little
squirrel
saving up more nuts than i really needed
and
not going very deep into my pile of nuts
and so that was it wasn't that
courageous and i kept one foot in the
law firm while i tried my capitalist
career
but as soon as the capitalist career
succeeded i intended to lift that second
foot
because i recognized that the potential
of law practice
as i saw it then i didn't anticipate the
boom that came to the big firms
i just saw it as being more difficult i
wanted more independence than i was
going to have
as a lawyer i hated sending other people
invoices
and needing money from richer people
i thought it was undignified i wanted my
own money
not because i loved ease or
social prison i wanted the independent
when i got to dallas i was a bartender
at night
and i moved in one of my buddies from
indiana said you got to come to dallas
and i'm like i'm there
you know my car would only get so far i
had a fiat x19 with a hole in the
floorboard that
guzzled oil every 60 miles and i went
down there and this place called the
village it's the world
was the world's largest apartment
complex we had six guys in a
three-bedroom apartment
i didn't have my own room i didn't have
my own drawer i didn't have my closet
i had a pile and i had one ratty towel
that i stole from
motel 6. and that was it and so
i was looking for my career got a job at
a software store
and i was you know i was didn't have a
tech background so i was teaching myself
all this because the way i look at tech
is somebody invents it
and everybody else is tied for second
place and the ability to learn it
and if if i work harder and faster
to really dive in if it means reading
the manual you know
just diving in then i can get a head
start
i was 24. and so sleeping on the floor
working in a software company
you know learning learning learning
learning learning getting better what i
was doing
and then one day because i was dying to
get out of that rat hole that i lived in
um i had a chance to go out and close
the sale
for that would he got me a 1500
commission and so i went to my boss his
name is michael humecki
and i said boss one of my
responsibilities was to sweep the floor
wipe down the windows and open the door
to open the store i got the sale you got
to let me close the sale
he goes no you got to be in there to
open the store and i'm like
michael i mean no so i made the
executive decision
to go out pick up the check thinking if
i hand this guy a 15 000
check of course he's going to change his
mind
fired me on the spot and so here i was
living in a [ __ ] excuse my french
you know just this ratty place with a
motel 6 towel sorry motel 6. um
and and really didn't know how i was
going to get out but
i went to i decided okay i'm a lousy
employee i went to
um one of the companies that i've been
talking to architectural lighting
and i said look um i need 500 to be able
to buy the software you want and i
promise you
that even if it doesn't work i will wash
your car you know i will walk your dog
i don't care what it is i will do
whatever it takes to make it up to you
and they gave me the 500
and that allowed me to create micro
solutions and you know six months later
i was out of the rat hole and
my company turned into a real company
and that's the one i sold um for six
million dollars
everyone thinks that spanx actually
started when i cut the feed out of my
pantyhose but the truth is it started
many many years before that
it started when i was selling fax
machines door-to-door
getting kicked out of office buildings
day in and day out
and i woke up one morning and i thought
i'm in the wrong movie
how did this happen this is not my life
cut scene call the director call the
producer
no and i took out a piece of paper and i
wrote down what i was good at
and there was not much on the page the
word
i saw the word sales i knew i was good
in sales so i wrote down
in my journal i want to invent a product
that i can sell to millions of people
that will make them feel good
and then i asked the universe for an
idea
and i waited for two years and the idea
showed up
and the minute i cut the feet out of my
pantyhose i decided to pursue it
so what do you do when you have an idea
and you've never
taken a business class or worked in
fashion or retail
i wanted to patent my idea and
i ended up looking for a female patent
attorney
and i called the georgia chamber of
commerce
and they said there actually wasn't a
single female patent attorney in the
entire state of georgia
so i looked in the yellow pages and
found three men's name and
went out and pitched my idea to them and
they actually thought the idea was so
bad that one of the patent lawyers later
admitted to me he thought i'd been sent
by candid camera
makes sense because he was looking
around the room for the hidden cameras
but he ended up
eventually helping me i went to barnes
noble bought a book on patents and
trademarks wrote my own patent
and went back to him and said please
please will you just write the claims
portion of it and
he did for a discounted price but it
makes me think about inventors and
innovators and when you hear those words
do you think of women
last year my son had inventor week at
his school
and they asked me to come and be the
keynote speaker at his kindergarten
class
so i was the inventor that was coming
and i started out looking at all these
cute little kids and i said
so what does an inventor look like and
all their hands shot up and one kid said
it's a man and he has crazy hair and
somebody else raised her in and said no
no it's a bald man
no it's a tall man it's a short man and
i just stopped and i said well i'm an
inventor
and their eyes got really big and they
said you are
and it dawned on me i looked around the
room and all the pictures of inventors
were albert einstein thomas edison steve
jobs so
i can see why the the young girl who
asked me and said i didn't know girls
could be inventors was surprised
and even my son on the way home he goes
mom you're an inventor
but the real point of all of this was i
wanted to help women and i'm so
passionate about it
and it's amazing that i started with
their butts and i've continued to groan
i started at the sarah blakely
foundation because i truly believe
that the world would be a much better
place if the male and female
energy on the planet was more balanced
when god created this planet
he created of several species
now if you're an atheist it's okay call
it the force
let me just say god for now so i don't
have to say god the forest god the
forest let's just say god right now
god creates a planet earth and first of
all he creates
which a lot of people in different
organizations want
a perfect social economic world where
everything is free don't worry about a
thing you're taken care of
there's no extra imagination necessary
it's all gonna be given to you so he
creates the oyster he says oyster
i'm giving you a free house to live in
i'm calling it a shell
i'm gonna put at the bottom of the ocean
to protect you from your enemies
you have food clothing all the food you
want
protection everything you want the
perfectly taken care of while you're in
your measly little life as an oyster
but you're not gonna go anywhere you
stay there at the bottom of the ocean
but you totally got your free food free
clothing free everything you want
then god created something called the
eagle eagle whole different species
eagle you want a house you go out and
build it take the top of a mountain take
the top of a tree
go out and build your own house you want
some food to eat
no problem go out there and find it
eagle
and the eagle flies through miles in the
winter time of
rain sleet snow and wind just to feed
the jung
did you know the eagle fails 95
of the time a total failure it's so big
and cumbersome that when it comes upon
its prey
they're wild they shoot off in a
different direction and it misses
five percent of the time it succeeds and
what does it succeed to do
it succeeded to be the strongest bird in
the sky
the only one that we know of anywhere in
the world that could fly into
the thermals of a hurricane and ride
them to have fun
now the eagle unlike the oyster can go
anywhere it wants anywhere it wants
yeah gambles it does this on its own but
it goes wherever it wants
now that eagle and not the oyster is the
emblem of america
and also on the flag of many many
countries you wouldn't be in this room
right now if you weren't eagles
don't only imagine start doing it thank
you peace love and happiness to all of
you thank you very much
thank you i talked a little bit about
focusing the company
and uh you know i think that uh
i want to talk a little bit about making
some big bets and
you know we always try to concentrate on
the long term uh what we're doing for
the long term
and you know i think that you know uh
many of the things we started up that
are really big now like chrome were seen
is kind of crazy
when we launch them and so how do we
decide what to do
what do you know how do we decide what's
really important to work on
i like to call the toothbrush test
so the toothbrush test is do you use it
as often as you use your toothbrush
and for most people i guess that's twice
a day raise your hand
twice a day yeah okay most people
so i think you know we really want
things like that and i think things like
gmail obviously
i use much more than twice a day
and youtube you know i think that uh
those things are amazing and i think
that uh
you know we look at things like youtube
people thought oh you guys are never
going to make money with that you bought
it for 1.4 billion dollars
you know you're totally crazy and we
were reasonably crazy but
it was a good bet and
we've actually been doubling revenue
every year on youtube for four years
and actually if you're doubling things
it starts to add up pretty quickly
even no matter where you start from
so i think that's a good example of the
how
sort of our philosophy is that we see
things that people use a lot
uh that they're gonna that are gonna be
really important to them
and we think that usually you can make
money from those things over time
uh you know a well-run technology
business
can be monetized over time when i
started my business
1995 it was very difficult
i had an idea i invited 24 of my friends
my apartment
because that year i went to seattle
first time my first trip to the usa
in seattle i discovered internet
and i think this thing in the future may
change the world
tell me about the encounter with the
internet when you first saw it yeah i
went to the
seattle and a friend of mine he had a
small office with like a four or five
computers
i never touched computer in my life
before because computer was so expensive
to me
and so complicated but my friend said
this is internet just to type in
whatever word
you want to type so no no too expensive
i don't know which one to do even now i
don't know how a computer works
they said jack it's not a bomb just a
typo whatever so the first
word i typed in was beer b-e-i beer i
don't drink
i don't know why a type of beer i found
american beer
german beer japanese beer no china so i
type the word
china there's no information about
china so i say hmm what if we can make
some china information on the internet
let people know about china so that was
the idea
so i came back to china and say i want
to resign
from my school you're a teacher i was a
teacher
i've been teaching in the university for
six years
so i said i want to do it i invite 24 of
my friends to my apartment
after two hours of explaining what i'm
gonna do
internet and 23 of them say forget it
he said this thing never worked because
there's no such thing called
internet in the world you know nothing
about a computer
so why you want to do this and um
only one people he said jack
if you want to try it just to try it but
if it's something wrong just come back
and uh after whole night thinking i say
i still want to do it because most of
the people
they have a fancy ideas in the evening
but in the date
when they wake up in the evening or in
the morning they go back to do the same
job
we have to do something different so
from there
i started my business borrowing 2000 us
dollars
from my relatives and friends well that
was
my trip i call myself like a blind man
riding on the back of blind tigers
and those people who are expert of
riding horses they all
fall down and i'm still surviving what
advice would you have
for managers or companies that are
really working through change and
struggling
let me define creative destruction
or i i will use uh schumpeter's
definition here's the way he put it it
is not
price and output competition which
counts
but the competition from the new product
the new technology
the new source of supply the new type of
organization
which commands a decisive cost or
quality advantage
and which strikes not at the margins
of the profits and the outputs but at
their foundations
and their very lives so that's what
we're talking about here this is
not life or death for us individually
but life and death
for our businesses and our jobs and so
what we do
to communicate this is get all our
employees to understand
that change is a risk for all of us
but not changing isn't a risk
it's suicide it is a certainty
that you are going out of business and
you are going to if you
individual employee if you're not
changing and improving
uh and working on that every day
you're not going to have your job
whereas if you take
what you think are risks and you find a
way to eliminate most of your job
because there's a way to do this more
efficiently or to bypass
do it a completely different way here at
coke you're not going to
lose your job you're going to be a hero
when i started amazon it was 25 years
ago
i started amazon in 1994
when i went to seek investors the first
question i had to answer
is what is the internet none of my
investors had ever heard of the internet
and uh the
the the the idea that i had in mind
was to build a bookstore i realized that
we could build a store
which would have every book ever printed
in any language in print or out of print
and we could do that online it would be
impossible in a physical store and that
was the founding idea of amazon
and but did i expect what would happen
today no you know we started
uh i've been at amazon when it was one
person
me when it was 10 people when it was 100
people when it was a thousand people
and today when it's you know more than
700 000 people and approaching 70
000 people just here in india so
no i did not predict that and actually i
think if anybody had predicted that they
would have needed to be immediately
institutionalized in a mental facility
because it's not a normal thing to have
happen my dream when i started amazon
was that one day we might be able to
afford a forklift
so it's been a very uh fun journey for
me
and by the way i still tap dance into
work i'm having so much fun there are
lots of times especially in the early
days
uh that were that were very very
difficult i think i think the most
difficult thing
experience i had was in 1990 when oracle
had its had its only lost quarter in
history and we've been in business for
20 years of the 20 years we lost money
one quarter
and we had a very difficult time um
because we had almo we doubled our sales
virtually every year for
for 10 years nine out of 10 years ten
out of 11 years it was really quite an
amazing run we're the
fastest growing company in history still
we still are the fastest growing company
in history
over a long period of time and
suddenly we'd hit a wall we would reach
a billion dollars in revenue and we were
having
serious management problems all over the
place and
the people who were running the company
at the billion dollar company were the
same people that
run the company when we were a 50
million dollar company 120th the size
and i hadn't had an incredible sense of
loyalty
to those people who'd worked with me to
build oracle
and it was a very painful realization
in 1990 that i was going to have to
change the management team that the
company had outgrown
the management uh that people who are
good at running a 50 million dollar
company are not necessarily those are
the same skills
it's not they're just different not one
is better or worse just entirely
different skill set
in running a 50 million dollar company
than a billion dollar company
and uh both skill sets are rare and
precious
but we needed a different group of
managers and virtually
the entire management team had to be
replaced and that means i had to ask
people
who i'd worked with for a decade to
leave i had to fire people
uh and that was the most difficult
the most the most difficult thing i had
to do in in business
asking that you know a bunch of people
to
leave oracle i had no choice and if they
asked them to leave oracle or everyone
would have to leave oracle because there
wouldn't be any oracle left
so it was in that sense it was a simple
choice
it was uh thousands of people worked at
oracle
deserve the best leadership we could
find
and my primary
my primary responsibility was to the
company and
all of the staff you know all of our
shareholders and all of our customers
and uh therefore i had to choose
and if i couldn't make that decision
then i had to go i want to offer a
cautionary tale
and again having both read your book and
also the notes that you kindly sent me
before this
um if you don't understand the subtlety
here you
you would conclude that the correct
thing to do is to grow everything as
fast you possibly can everywhere
right so let's just make as many
engineers as many sales people as many
products
and so on and so on that completely does
not work
and it doesn't work because no product
shall ship
before it actually works right
and the way you build great products is
you have small teams with
strong leaders who obsess over
trade-offs and they push things off and
they say we've got to get it done and
they put a lot of pressure on the team
they work all night and they produce a
product that just barely works
okay the original used non-google
examples the original ipod
just barely worked look at what it
became try people remember the original
iphone
no apps right everyone's forgotten that
just barely worked but it just was just
the right combination
to create an enormous franchise that's
now 70 percent
of the revenue of the world's most
valuable company i was talking to travis
clonic
we are uh major
investors inside of uber so we have good
relations with uber
and his description of uber was that
he understood scaling but the product
the app wasn't ready
so so you have to sort of have judgment
about when the product is ready to scale
against
it and um so we would debate this over
and over again
and so larry and sugar would play tricks
on me so typical example would be
i would say we're not strong enough to
take on microsoft
and they wanted to do an operating
system in a browser and i said there's
no scenario where we'll ever do an
operating system in a browser
and because microsoft will kill us and i
don't want to get killed we're a small
company and yes yes you're very smart
yes yes we're full of smart people and
yes yes we have lots of revenue
these guys can kill us because i'd been
previously killed in the previous jobs
and so they hired somebody to in to
improve the performance of firefox
um six months later i'm called down to
one office and
the person who is supposed to improve
the performance of firefox has managed
to invent chrome
shocking and i say well how long you've
been doing this
well i've been doing it on the side no
you haven't you've done it full time
well yeah you know three other people
okay well how many more people do you
have oh ten more people
well did larry okay did larry and sergey
know about this larry and sorry
encouraged it i said
those [ __ ] right you know i knew it
i knew they were going around me
right okay
um so and then i said well we can't do
an operating system
so they bought this company called
android and they said yeah yeah it's
just for smartphones it's software for
smartphones don't worry eric
today android is 1.4 billion 1.4 billion
plus operating systems use largest
number of operating systems in the world
chrome is the largest the most
successful browser so
maybe the lesson to learn in management
is i'm just wrong all the time
but but the secret was you sort of you
have to have judgment as to when these
things can
scale right and i can give you plenty of
negative examples
um an obvious one is wave right it was a
complicated email product
that uh we launched um to great fanfare
and we watched its adoption rate marissa
had this rule
which is a good rule that you cannot
google you cannot tell how successful a
product is until the first six months
because what happens is you get this
adoption cycle and everyone loves the
product because everyone tests it and
then you watch what happens
and the great products you know they're
bumpy but they go up well this is what
it looked like like this
so it took eric your friendly ceo 18
months
of going down straight down before the
project was canceled right
so again lack of due diligence last so
the reason i'm answering your question
in the the blitz growth argument
by saying you've got to have the
products that you can scale
if you have the products that can scale
the thing that's new is you can scale
very quickly
the uber example once you have
an app and a business model that more or
less works there's no reason why you
shouldn't go global and wide maybe i'll
just blank out the word doubt
[Laughter]
so no i mean i tritoli frank i doubted
us too
so i thought we you know had maybe
when starting spacex maybe had a 10
chance of reaching orbit so
so you know to those who doubted us i
was like well i think you're probably
right
you know um i mean there were times uh
that i was told like uh because i was
taking the
money i learned from from paypal and
enrolling into
to create spacex and tesla and and i
ended up spending it all
it wasn't the intention but um
and and and uh almost both companies
went bankrupt frankly
2008 was a tough year um
you know it took us took us four
attempts just to get to orbit with
falcon 1.
um and uh so but a lot of times i was
you know i people would tell me this
joke like how do you make a small
fortune in
the rocket industry you start with a
large one is the punch line
and i was like okay i already heard that
joke 12 000 times you know
so so anyway um
and it was it almost came true um
you know we just barely made it there
that fourth launch
of falcon one that's all the money we
had for that fourth launch
and then uh and that wasn't even enough
to save the company we also then had to
win the nasa cargo resupply contract
um so that that came a little after you
know a little bit later
or towards the end of 2008 those are the
two
key things that that saved spacex
otherwise we would have we would have
you know not made it so
um so yeah i think those those doubters
were
their probability assessment was correct
but fortunately
veda smiled upon us and brought us to
this day one time when you were doing
hot air ballooning
you weren't sure whether you would
survive with the ballooning adventures
i was doing something that um
that nobody had done before uh i was
um you know trying to you know fly
across the atlantic or the pacific or or
go around the world in
a balloon i was flying at you know 40
000 feet in in the jet stream um you
know with one
with one other person pure linstrand um
and uh and you know the technology was
completely unproven they were
we were the test pilots that was more
dangerous things could go wrong and they
did go right you set a number of
guinness world records for that
but in hindsight do you have any regrets
about taking those risks
on the hot air balloon it's interesting
um
you know my son and daughter now uh
are setting themselves big adventures
every year um dragging their dad along
on some of them you know and i think as
a family we feel
you know live life live life to its full
and
um and you know you you can
uh you know you can uh you can you can
die in a road accident you can die on a
just a normal bike ride
and and quite often when you're actually
completely focused on an adventure
and the it's less likely in some way
that you're going to
die in an adventure because you're
you're ready and sharp and
and know how to deal with it the biggest
thing for me on that on that path is
i need to i need to draw something out
and i need to get it out of my head i
found myself very early on
thinking about something like you know
thinking about this this early idea for
twitter
and saying to myself i could build this
awesome
you know you have those like shower
moments or you're walking at midnight
in some town in new york city and you've
got these amazing brand ideas
and and then you start thinking well i
could really start doing this
if only x and if i had this person
or if this technology existed or if this
happened or this happened
and what i what i realized i was doing
is i constantly making excuses for not
working on it
and then the window had passed and then
i couldn't do anything
so i think it's really really important
to
write it out or to draw it out or to
code it but you need to get out of your
head
and the reason you have to get it out of
your head is you need to be able to see
it on a surface that is not
in your mind and once you can see it
once you can step back from it then you
can also decide
uh this is you know this passes my
filter
passes my you know constraints so maybe
i can show it and share with some other
people
and then they'll be like you know that's
the stupidest idea ever
and or you know that's somewhat
interesting
but maybe this and this and this um so
the sooner you can do that
then you have a lot of momentum around
it and you can you know really decide if
you want to
commit to it and work on it more or
put it on the shelf for a later date
and the realization that i think
everyone needs to have about that
latter option putting on the shelf is
that you can come back to it and
it'll it'll surface back up in another
piece of work or another idea
at some point in your life so you know
having that
having that ability to close off a
chapter and move on
is really really important you can't
have all these open threads and and
that's what i realized i was doing
and and that also encouraged me to to
really write more
and to really think about you know what
is what is the
story what how are people coming to this
and like when i show my friends this
how are they going to react and i would
write it down i would actually treat it
like
a play and and and when i realized that
i was writing plays i wrote i read
a lot more plays for style and for
substance and for technique and
i think it's you know i think it's i
think it's really good and i think
there's another company that i've always
looked
towards for inspiration and
i know a number of people in this room
probably have a
similar company in mind which is apple
apple
i think is run like a theater company
it has a great sense of pacing has a
great sense of story
and has a great sense of execution and
it's all about
it's all event driven it's all stage
driven the stage being a billboard or
the stage being a keynote or the stage
being a product launch
all of it has a very very cohesive end
to end story i mean you think about what
happened when steve jobs
came back to the company the first thing
he did is he killed
every product line the company was
working on
and for two years they had no product on
the market whatsoever
all they had were a bunch of posters all
around the world with steve's heroes
and it said think different and it was
just focused on bringing up the brand
and
making people aware of the brand again
and how the brand is aligning to this
particular
feeling and story and then
they came out with the imac and then
built built itunes and then
the ipod and they realized that wait a
minute
people are carrying music on their
phones now so we better build a phone
build iphone and so this this unfolding
of the plot and the epic story has has
been very very interesting to watch
especially if you look back you know to
that that time when he came back
to the company so i've learned a lot
from that company
and other companies who operate in a
similar fashion when you look at it you
know it is really not
common for somebody to leave banking
and go and start something totally new
you know especially in an
area of events management because at the
time that she left the bank
which was 10 years ago nobody thought
that
something like events management will
actually succeed but i mean it is good
that is
really what you call entrepreneurship
and also a vision you know she had a
vision and she
is able to actualize our vision uh it's
just like myself
i remember one time i went to
address a retreat of first bank of
nigeria and i was selling first worker
for nigeria
this is where the is going to be in the
next five years i mean they were not
really that big at the time that i went
there to
address them and i'm sure you know they
couldn't really believe what i was
saying
then but i remember uh at a point
the md said that well you know they are
really shocked at
how we actually been able to make it and
also
actualize our vision so i think with
this thing that she has
done i personally believe it is just
beginning of the
journey because she has a vision and i'm
sure if she continues to do this can
turn into another mega business you know
because
like what i always say look
for an entrepreneur there are no
boundaries not only are there no
boundaries
you can actually excel much more than
your own expectation
and that's really what i expect of an
entrepreneur to be
not to just say okay fine i have a
vision and only achieve that your vision
you
need to have a vision and a mission so
that you can actually
actualize it and also excel i mean i had
somebody
who came to interview me one time and i
told him that yes you know three four
five years ago
i never ever expected myself to be on
the forbes
list but right now the vision that i
have
and also my own mission is actually to
be on top of the light
not even where i am today and that's
really how
you know a visionary person should be my
father
started reliance with a hundred dollars
right when i joined reliance in 1980
the market value of reliance was
30 or 40 million dollars and
in 30 years right the opportunities that
were provided
by this country has enabled us
to create wealth for india
my father was a big believer that
any business that has the
sole purpose of making money is not
worth doing
right business must serve
a larger societal purpose reliance
raised all its money from capital
markets
and from individual small shareholders
so we've created a million millionaires
just by investing
in reliance out of ordinary indians and
that is the process
of creating wealth for the country
once you create opportunity
wealth comes
is
one of the things that really hurt apple
was after i left
john scully got a very serious disease
and that disease i've seen other people
get it too it's um
it's the disease of thinking that a
really great idea is 90
of the work and that if you just tell
your all these other people
you know here's this great idea then of
course they can go off and make it
happen
and the problem with that is is that
there's a just
a tremendous amount of craftsmanship
in in between a great idea and a great
product
and as you evolve that great idea it
changes and grows it never comes out
like it starts because you learn a lot
more as you get into the subtleties of
it and you also find
there's tremendous trade-offs that you
have to make i mean you know there are
there are just certain things you you
can't make electrons do there are
certain things you can't make plastic do
or glass do
and and as you get into or factories do
what robots do
and as you get into all these things
designing a product is keeping
5 000 things in your brain
these concepts and fitting them all
together
in in kind of continuing to push to fit
them together in new and different ways
to get what you want and every day you
discover something new
that is a new problem or a new
opportunity to fit these things together
a little differently
and it's that process
that is the magic
and so we had a lot of great ideas when
we started
but what i've always felt
that a team of people doing something
they really believe in is like is like
when i was a young kid
um there was a um a widowed man that
lived up the street
and uh he was in his 80s
uh he's a little scary looking and and i
got to know him a little bit
um i think he might have paid me to cut
his mow his lawn or something
and one day he said come on into my
garage i want to show you something and
he pulled out this dusty old rock
tumbler
it was a motor and a and a coffee can
and a little
you know band between them and he said
come on with me we went out to the back
and we got some just some rocks some
regular old
ugly rocks and we put them in the can
with a little bit of
liquid and a little bit of of grit
powder and we closed the can
up and he turned this motor on he said
come back tomorrow
and as can was making a you know racket
as the stones
and i came back the next day and we took
we opened the can
and we took out these amazingly
beautiful polished rocks
[Music]
um the same
common stones that had gone in through
rubbing against each other like this
creating a little bit of friction
creating a little bit of noise had come
out these beautiful polished rocks
and that's always been in my mind my
metaphor
for a team working really hard on
something they're passionate about is
is that it's through the team through
that group of incredibly talented people
bumping up against each other having
arguments having fights sometimes making
some noise
and working together they polish each
other
and they polish the ideas and what comes
out are these really beautiful
stones so
it's hard to explain um and it's
certainly not the result of one person
i mean people like symbols so i'm the
symbol of certain things but
it really is it was a team effort on the
mac now
in my life i observed something fairly
early on
uh at apple um
which i i didn't know how to explain it
then but i've thought a lot about it
since
if you most things in life the dynamic
range between average and the best is at
most two to one
right like if you go to new york city
and you get an average taxi cab driver
versus the best taxi cab driver
you know you're probably going to get to
your destination with the best taxi cab
maybe
30 percent faster you know in an
automobile what's the difference between
an average and the best maybe on
20 percent uh the best cd player in an
average cd player i know 20 percent
so two to one is a big big dynamic range
in most of life
um in software
and it used to be the case in hardware
too the difference between
average and the best is fifty to one
maybe a hundred to one
easy okay i've very few things in life
are like this
but what i was lucky enough to spend my
life in
is like this and so i've built
a lot of my success off finding these
truly gifted people and not settling for
b and c
players but really going for the a
players and i found something
i found that when you get enough a
players together when you go to
through the incredible work to find you
know five of these eight players
they really like working with each other
because they've never had a chance to do
that before
and they don't want to work with b and c
players
and so it becomes self-policing and they
only want to hire more a
players and so you build up these
pockets of a players and it propagates
and that's what the mac team was like
they were all a players and um
these were extraordinarily talented
people six albums original
albums of of your own a throne record
various records were good music to talk
about man but seriously yeezus
bravo dude i mean that is one of the
most creative records of you know of any
genre i've heard in a very very long
time and
you know just in terms of your output
your most exciting sounding record i
think man
oh thank you very much you know yeah i
feel you know
i was able to start just making exactly
what was in my mind
again and not having to speak with the
textures of the time
because you know cruel summer is
definitely kanye west and it's something
kind of weird and off about mercy like
when it has the high
pitch that type of sound it sounds like
art still a little bit
even though it's obviously it was a
radio smash uh
but it's still when when i you know get
into the idea like the trap drums and
things like that are certain
you know songs that are blatant you know
radio hits it's like i'm speaking with
today's textures
and that's you know and you look if you
look at it 200 years from now it's not
going to stand out in the way that
you know 808 or jesus stands out
and completely can push or redefine or
make people say
you know hey i completely hate that or i
completely love that
but let me just think differently
because everybody is like bound to these
you know
um no pun intended they're bound to uh
16 bars and eight bars and you know the
normal
uh radio uh
the radio thing i was talking to frank
ocean about this and said like you know
my mom got arrested for the sit-ins
and now we're more like the sit outs
like sit off of radio
yeah and say hey radio come to us yeah
you know we need to find something new
because it's being
you know controlled in a way and and
manufactured in a way that
you you know uh really awesome you know
artists
you know uh can make amazing music and
and not break
as far past is like something that's
very like formulaic so it almost feels
like a duty to you in a weird way having
the people's ear having people's
attention and
for great music to be able to say well
if i'm not challenging them if i'm not
challenging myself not challenging radio
what am i doing
yeah well i'm not i'm not trying to
regurgitate myself i showed i showed
people that i understand how to make
perfect you know dark fantasy could be
considered to be perfect you know i say
i know how to make perfect but that's
not what i'm here
to do i'm here to crack and crack the
pavement and make
new grounds you know sonically and in
society culturally
you have an enormous skill with branding
and
marketing and rebranding what
what would you give as advice to small
and medium-sized business owners
for branding and marketing well the
first thing is you have to have a good
product if you don't have the product
forget it but assuming they have a
really good product you have to get the
word out you know i know people
that are better singers more talented
than frank sinatra
you'll never hear about them i know one
in particular
a person who really is talented always
practicing always rehearsing
and yet if the new york times calls for
an interview no no no i'm not ready yet
i'm not ready yet they're never ready
you got to get out and do it also you
have to sort of let the press know that
you exist
getting good ratings on things like i
have golf courses that have high ratings
and then once you get the ratings you
got to let people know you have the
ratings
it's a long process and it takes a long
time
[Music]
if you want to get inside the mindset of
a billionaire investor check out the
video
right there next to me i think you'll
love it continue to believe
and i'll see you there you look at the
most successful people in the world i
know very few of them that haven't had a
major failure
the investing business you can learn by
reading you know read everything warren
buffett's ever written
watch every youtube video he's ever
appeared